Continental Tire Coach's Corner brings
us well it should be Continental Tire
former Coaches Corner because he's not
really a coach over 125,000 people
watched that video that we sent to you
my friend Jimmy Bristow but every other
morning says hey because you watch the
show and you kept saying hey tell those
guys to stop shooting I said what I said
was only Dan shoots on TV but that's
basically what is said
I mean I got I got all these text
messages I saved it and you ripped these
guys and I just said only Dan should
shoot on TV take that however you want
but that was a compliment to you I took
it I know that I'm a good shooter I just
felt bad for the look at these guys they
have nothing going on in their lives and
then you are ripping them and I thought
why are you acting like Bob night all of
a sudden here well I did act like Bob
night one time in the locker room I was
I was doing an imitation him when I was
a player and he walked in oh no let me
see your Bob night you can't do Bob
night unless you can swear I'm being
totally oh so I ended the whole thing by
pointing at my chair and you mother and
he was rolling in the back my guy was
looking like and offers like you're good
you're good and I'm like so but you
can't you can't do Bob Knight unless
unless you're swearing it's just no good
so Bob didn't say anything - he laughed
like crazy
and he laughed so hard and he said let's
go it was before practice and so let's
go see what Coach not used to do was he
was like literally if we had a meeting
at 6:00 he would show up at 8:00 and you
would all be sitting there like just
like dummies literally you'd be sitting
there like we got a kid Chuck Franz who
kept a blog we had these notebooks and
he would keep how late coach night was
for meetings and it was all her a day we
sat in there true story okay so what's
the message that he's sending to honey
he just got back from Beirut or anyway
literally you would come in and say he
would be in hunting gear and you'd be
like all right
we'll see you guys tomorrow and that'd
be okay but that first practice where
you start to hear that language and and
you know Bob is let you knew what you
were getting into when you write like
the idea that kids get bothered by it is
so disrespectful to kids like I didn't
come to Indiana and all of a sudden a
guy's swearing at me and I'm gonna be
upset by their Aaron Henry isn't go you
can't do it now you can you just can't
do it on TV
yeah coaches are a little bit I think a
lot of bit actually certain coaches are
you know you are beholden to your team
I'll tell you this my first practice
I'll never forget it was the year after
Isiah won national championship so it's
81 but it's in the fall right and you
couldn't you didn't have workouts like
you do now you just simply started
practice October 15th we had some
running stuff and I swear to God my
first practice the first drill I'm in a
stance and I think I'm doing good stop
oh did you ever play d French in yer
okay I'm good you know I weigh 110
pounds literally I'm in practice and I
look at Mike Fox I've managed I go Mike
I'm gonna die how much more he looks at
his watch you couldn't look at your
watch and practice with coach Knight and
he kind of looked he goes we've been
going 45 minutes you got two hours
literally literally was
gonna die so it was so hard did he ever
make you cry no no no he hit me in the
face with a ball twice here in Minnesota
it's in season on the brink he he got it
he got anyone into play and I was a
freshman and we're playing zone we're
playing Minnesota zone and he gets it
he's gonna show Ted kitchen or Annie
Whitman how the pass against I strip it
from him he's on top I'm in the zone and
I'd steal it so he gets in I can tell
he's man he goes again he goes and make
a pass true story I just gonna sound bad
all right he takes a dribble and I'm in
a stance in my face is exposed takes a
dribble and throws a ball hits me right
in the face
that's what happened here face and then
so I give him the ball and I'm really in
his stance and he does it again
drills me right here since season under
it drills right in the face and now I
turn I'm like I'm coming yeah mother you
know and he spins me around by my
shoulder and I got my fists clenched cuz
I wasn't it I didn't that was it I had
nothing and yeah I saw him back up and
he's a guy we're going on to something
else well after practice he calls me
onto the court over here Williams Arena
and he says were you gonna punch me I
said you know I'm a freshman I said
coach I was gonna knock your ass I said
I'm sorry but you just hit me in a face
twice to the basketball and then all of
a sudden I'm spun around and it's kind
of funny this is how sick I am I was
really kind of happy about it because I
didn't play the game before and I knew
he was gonna feel so bad that I was it's
a sickness of played at Indiana in the
eighties brother but do you think that
he was testing your toughness no I think
he literally got mad okay because here's
a freshman stealing the ball from me
okay and I wasn't you I guess later
randy wittman and ted Kitchel told me
whenever he gets into practice you just
let him make passes like a whip on over
your shoulder lazy I didn't know that I
was just a freshman are you worried
about his legacy well I don't I mean I
don't want to sound harsh but I don't
like him I don't care okay anything I
don't have a relationship I don't want a
relationship I want to be
around him I don't want to see him I
don't care when did it change you know
over years you know I was there sixteen
years with him and when I left he was
really nasty he really said some bad
things about me to high school coaches
and I called him on he and his son Timmy
just because you left and you were going
to well now we're gonna get good dockets
didn't do this well I'm like I was there
sixteen years I mean and then so I
called him on it and he apologized but
are you doing that for and then when
when he got fired in the end it wasn't
his fault it was all our fault
it wasn't Isaiah's fault it wasn't
Buckner's fault it was it was the you
know guy like me who worked for him who
he could cast aside and then when I went
the ESPN he I said a lot of things
behind behind the scenes to people that
I didn't appreciate he just he just
hasn't been a very loyal guy to me and I
feel like over 16 years I was a very
loyal guy done stupid loyal like my name
of my book is no man is a hero to his
valet because I he is pretty much his
valet and you know I I just I just don't
I don't like why did you stay so long
because I was told I was gonna be head
coaching Indiana by him yeah yeah I mean
you stay here then I'm gonna quit midway
through and midway through a year and
then you're gonna be the head coach so I
thought you know Marshall offered me to
job twice once before Billy Donovan got
it high for five schools and then when
when Bowling Green came over I I had to
get out of it I'd had enough of him and
he probably had enough for me I just had
to get out we're talking to Dan dockage
I'm looking at my face there is
something wrong ladies are you just
noticing your I don't believe in my own
mind my hair looks good no my no it just
looks bad
you're a Picasso painting in real life
yeah you're all like your stuffs all
over the place
no I'm shaving my head when the season's
over I'm coming home really yeah it's
not you that I'm gonna put some
advertising on the face
she did it I have frizzy looks really
good he done can I say one thing about
Fritzi yeah I love how much he loves his
family I do I love when Prince E gets
going about so what you're saying is we
don't love our fault but you just love
how much he talks about his bar mitzvahs
and what he does for his kids did he ask
you to do a video more sympathy for your
wife now you're looking at yourself on
camera and you're going oh my god she's
got a look at this if you look at my
wife and this is true
she literally gets mistaken constantly
for Jennifer Aniston true story look up
Lee Ross on Twitter her picture on ESPN
is right next to Jennifer how did you
pull that I'm not bad to hang out with
I'm fun to hang out I don't have to
marry you though I could just hang with
you maybe she thought you were like to
make-a-wish kid that's why we get caught
up in Zion Williamson and Zion
williamson's you know the most exciting
basketball player in history that we've
ever seen is there a college basketball
player you remember now wouldn't have
this hype I don't you know social media
made Zion explode and the fact that
Dukes on national TV but from the
entertainment aspect of this as anybody
ever come close to Zion first scene you
were talking to Grant Hill I think
Christian Laettner did back in the day I
mean you think about if you really think
about Duke in those days basketball was
great I think grant played up to three
years ago I mean Calbert Cheaney played
for us for four we played them and add
the game after late in there hit the
shot in the Final Four here in
Minneapolis the truth of the matter is
Laettner before social if you would have
put social media into that era
don't you think Laettner would have been
probably beyond even what Diane
Williamson because you got to remember
they have the highlights oh I think he's
got better highlights then Zion I'm not
talking about
don't splinter how about Seton Hall as
freshmen area I mean game winners of
this guy here I know him the biggest yes
moment I'm not talking about beating
kanesha I'm right there with you
so I'm saying I'm just talking about
excitement the blocks and the dunks was
I on I get all that but you it but I'm I
guess I'm answering more let's just say
Instagram followers okay if Laettner did
what he did for four years now right
if Laettner did what he did in this era
of Instagram and Twitter I think he
would I think he would be beyond words I
now I get what you're saying
he's polarized yes people love Sonia
when's the last time we love to do play
I got to go back to Grant Hill Grant
Hill was the most lovable Duke player
until Zion Williams yeah I mean how do
you I don't know what is what role as
parents played in just how he could stay
sort of in that moment of being a kid
enjoying celebrating knowing what he's
got coming down the road maybe that's
why he said it could move like but he
doesn't play selfishly dan I've said
this I think sine Williamson's the
smartest basketball player in college
basketball this year I know he's the
most talented I know he runs I know he
jumps I know he's strong but I think
he's the smartest basketball when you
watch him play basketball I saw this in
the Syracuse games it's gonna sound
really nerdy basketball stupid but
there's a loose ball on the floor and I
watched this for myself
he didn't just dive on the pile for the
loose ball he dove where the ball was
you understand I'm saying like he and
then I'm watching him in the middle of
his own and I'm watching him in the
middle of zone catch the basketball and
what you do with that you look shot you
look down you look opposite did all that
with poise took his time and then I'm
watching him on defense and the balls
opposite him and Duke has a rule that it
get it's basically this two passes away
you're in the middle of the lane or
maybe but he's always in the right spot
and that to me is intelligence that to
me is basketball smarts I'm telling you
why don't you coaching anymore me
because I like my life okay nobody's
offered me a job okay
I know I didn't but yes I did you know I
mean like my wife is there and I like my
life and you're doing great
I'm having fun and I can't tell you how
much I'm pretty I just don't know why
you guys bother me so much
I'm just look at it because you're if
you allow us I'm Bob Knight with the
ball and throwing it in your face is
really figuratively I'm not gonna
reenact that like you did would do lit
grant I'm not doing it during the live
look in we want to see if you've ever
wanted to see Dan Duquette shoot and
nobody coach Knight didn't want to see
him shoot I'm gonna have you go against
the dance and then like just shoot just
shoot just shoot let's see what you got
shot one ball in five years let's bring
out the violin yeah you're sad
you had it you sent me you sent me a
picture of you with a basketball and
your Harvard t-shirt on I sent you don't
at me yesterday me drilling a three on
the court over here it I will tell you
it took one take but the truth is about
20 takes it's what I thought and by
McGrath who was video it says Dan
dockage ESPN college basketball analyst
joining us Continental Tire coaches
pointer will come back by the way Bruce
Pearl top of the hour and Chris beard
will join us in the final hour as well
Dan dockage puts on a shooting display
that would make Steve Alford jealous
right after this were you were you a
good shooter no I did everything left
yeah I scored coach tonight came to see
me 30 at half at 49 in the game they
came to the state finals at 35 maybe 33
and then get to college and it's off
okay where's your where's your spot
right here right there autofill excuse
me right there that's McLovin right
there
yeah we'll move it over a little bit Wow
56 years old boys 56 years old yeah
he's hooking he's hooking but you never
got to shoot at Indiana you got a great
Oh you sit in you got a pawprint oh babe
why would you want to go to Indiana and
play in that hello
I loved every minute oh I loved every
day I did my college career tight
fighting in the middle how about when
you guarded Jordan tell us tell us
use your Michael George I'll be George
are you George or I'll he's gonna make
please don't make puzzle
I'll tell you this Dan we got time yeah
I think how much time we got
come here yeah you got it on the block
okay so Michael Jordan has me on the
Block yeah all right
he turns this way like he turns for a
jump shot yeah swear to god he jumps up
I look up
this is swear got true he's the way and
I thought during the shot I cream of
dole Jabbar can't block this shot like
I'm thinking that when he shoot in the
moment like in the moment so he gets you
on the Block he knows he keeps going up
so I won I won the contest appreciate
y'all having me namely Patrick church
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]